monsieur oui bonjour merci d'être en
direct sur arte france alors la
situation sanitaire est de plus en plus
difficile
on le voit bien dans certains hôpitaux
la grève et même d'actualité un pour le
personnel soignant
où en sont justement les promesses du
plan singer pour l'instant les promesses
du plan c durant les absolument pas vu
les 4000 le poste qui était promis ne
sont toujours pas arrivés comme vous
l'avait dit et puis surtout c'est 4000
postes et une goutte d'eau c'est à dire
que le week-end dernier il ya eu 4000
suppressions de postes donc en réalité
on rattrape absolument rien du tout ça
fait déjà plusieurs années que les
autres les soignants alerte sur le
sous-effectif chronique notamment à
l'hôpital
et aujourd'hui on va trappe absolument
pas ce retard là à l'ap-hp il ya des
suppressions de postes mais en plus de
ça il ya une précarisation des postes il
ya 3500 emplois perrin qui ont été
supprimés au profit d'emplois précaires
donc en fait on se retrouve avec un
personnel en sous-effectif et en plus de
ça qui est précarisé qui changent tout
le temps de service et qui ne ne peut
pas s'adapter à ce nouveau virus
chaque année les épidémies saisonnières
sans parler du coc vide m l'hôpital à
genoux et aujourd'hui on va se retrouver
en plus avec les malades du co lead et
là ça va devenir extrêmement compliqué à
gérer
et du coup les mesures qu'il fallait
prendre et qui aurait dû être prise
c'était un plan d'embauchés massives
notamment à l'hôpital ont aussi dans les
ehpad il fallait deux cent mille postes
de plus à l'hôpital
cent mille à l'hôpital pardon cernil à
l'hôpital de 100000 en ehpad cent mille
dhs en ambulatoire en ville pour
l'instant on a
mais de ça donc on sait pas comment on
va pouvoir gérer le nombre de malades
qui arrivent d'autant plus que ça va se
rajouter aux épidémies saisonnières
qu'on connaît déjà
alors vous êtes vous à marseille on sait
que marc faye est en alerte maximale le
soutien le virus est toujours très actif
quelle est la situation dans les
hôpitaux mais la situation elle et elle
est relativement stable pour le moment
mais elle est quand même tendu on a très
peu de marge de manoeuvre les taux de
saturation des lits de l'eas sont très
élevés alors effectivement il ya un des
critères qui a été donnée par le
ministre sait que 30 % des lits drea
sont remplies par le conte vide
on comprend le la mesure mais simplement
il fallait lui expliquer que si on
voulait pas atteindre ces 30% il fallait
augmenter le nombre de lits dryats le
nombre de leaders on les a soi-disant
doublé pour pendant la première vague et
on l'a on et revenir aux niveaux d'avant
la première vague
donc il ya une incompréhension totale
quant à la capacité du gouvernement à
déployer délit quand y en a besoin et
surtout à les déployer de manière
pérenne
la dernière mesure en date qui a été
prise pour l'hôpital par le ministre
c'est un décret qui est passé en
catimini le 3 septembre et qui facilite
les suppressions de postes preuve qu'ils
n'ont absolument rien compris et
absolument pas changé leur braqués sur
comment ils vont faire avec l'hôpital et
comment en fait ils sont en train de le
sacrifier
est ce qu'aujourd'hui la grèce c'est le
seul moyen de se faire entendre on sait
que par exemple à l'hôpital du kremlin
bicêtre le chef de service des urgences
a démissionné il ya des grèves aussi
qu'ils ont commencé à partir du 1er
octobre à partir de jeudi nîmes rennes
ou encore morlaix et puis il ya un appel
qui a été lancée par la cfdt pour une
mobilisation le 13 octobre
est ce que c'est le seul moyen de se
faire entendre malheureusement on n'a
pas d'autre chose
c'est à dire que des grèves y en a déjà
eu dans le passé je te rappeler que
juste avant le compass dans la première
vague de l'épidémie
le personnel soignant faisait grève
depuis des mois était dans la rue depuis
des mois pour demander les mêmes choses
qu'aujourd'hui
donc on vous comprenez bien que la
situation à ne s'est pas améliorée avec
l'apparition du pôle its bien au
contraire et aujourd'hui on n'a pas
d'autre choix que d'essayer de faire
entendre à l'opinion qui a un énorme
problème et la grève reste le seul moyen
qu'on a parce que c'est ce gouvernement
n'entend rien
il refuse d'écouter il refuse de
concerter surtout il refuse de prendre à
bras le corps les problèmes du pays
il supprime aujourd'hui les bars et les
restaurants
prétextant que ce serait là qui aurait
le plus de contamination ok parce que en
intérieur quand on n'a pas de masque
effectivement on a plus de risque de
contaminer les autres
mais la réalité c'est que quand on
regarde les chiffres des clusters la
l'immense majorité d'entre eux se passe
en lien avec le travail que ce soit les
écoles les les amphithéâtres pour les
étudiants ou le travail en entreprise ou
les transports c'est là qu'est le gros
des contaminations dans si on voulait
être efficace sur la diffusion du virus
il fallait peut-être augmenter le nombre
de lignes de métro et de rer
de professeurs pour limiter le nombre
d'enfants par classe
il fallait peut-être rétablir les chsct
les comités hygiène et sécurité qui ont
été détruits par ce gouvernement et qui
aurait pu en cas d'avis défavorable sur
les conditions sanitaires permettre aux
travailleurs d'exercer d'exercer leur
droit de retrait et débrancher
l'inspection du travail pour que les
conditions sanitaires sont réunies et
qu'on limite les contaminations
donc là on a des coups d'épée dans l'eau
on va voir dans quelques semaines que
l'ensemble des gangs il va finir par
passer en alerte maximale puisque les
mesures qu'ils ont prises vont pas du
tout à ralentir la circulation du virus
est qu'en aval
on n'a absolument rien prévu pour
accueillir les malades qui vont arriver
en particulier en réanimation parce que
c'est ça le vrai difficulté
le virus s'est pas le virus lui-même
c'est vraiment est-ce qu'on a assez de
lits pour accueillir les malades si on
en a assez
alors on sait très bien traitée
aujourd'hui cette pathologie
on sait très bien traité les cas graves
qu'on a réduit les temps
d'hospitalisation
on a réduit le nom de la mortalité mais
dès qu'on a plus de livret a c'est ça le
vrai danger là on va voir les morts se
multiplier donc aujourd'hui l'urgence
c'est de réinvestir massivement dans
l'hôpital et dans la médecine de ville